[Music]
to New York big solo premiere where star
Emilia Clarke was still feeling the love
from her country's recent royal wedding
celebration
I did watch it and I'm just so I just
think it's beautiful the 7-month they
just it's beautiful in here it's happy
and like what on it's gorgeous
so amelia is just like us obsessed with
Megan and Harry she's also pitching
herself that she's now in the Star Wars
galaxy you look good little rough around
the edges that's the amazing thing about
Star Wars you can't not be proud about
it with Game of Thrones shooting his
final season Amelia dropped one scoop
she shed tears over every single script
I'm about 3/4 of the way through filming
if not maybe a little bit more and I am
anything him Tom Donald Glover is so low
a Star Wars stories Lando Calrissian
his young son is taken with the toy
version of death he doesn't even think
of it as Lana he's like oh this is just
a daddy action figure which is kind of
Awesome oh my god this viral et moment
of Harrison Ford surprising the film's
new solo Alden Ehrenreich well the stars
are still talking about when I was like
the fact that he took the time to come
out and do that just met the world it
was really a special make sense that he
did cuz hair supposedly loved the film
[Music]